The answer is this one, the ball is moving down to the right and just think if we were throwing
a real ball up a tower, its path would look something like this.
In any instant we can approximate the direction it's moving, a straight line like this
and yeah sure enough it goes down to the right.
Remember, whenever you ask a qualitative answer like this one in physics,
well, physics describes reality.
You should never provide an answer that disagrees with what you think would actually happen.
Okay, so how do we get this answer.
With this blue arrows are what we call components of the balls velocity.
We've already mentioned the horizontal component and this one we'll call the vertical component.
Those two together create the balls resulting velocity but they have to be added appropriately.
The way we do that is we imagine sliding this horizontal vector down,
so its tail matches with this guy's tip and we can also slide this vertical one over here.
Now we've created this nice rectangular shape where those meet we draw our line
and we have our resulting velocity.
This is going to come in handy when we wanted to do some trigonometry later,
and just to give you a hint we can already see the right triangles forming.
Now this has been talked about in a very abstract sort of way.
Let's actually solve a problem so we know what's going on.